Could you now tell us which is
considered to be the most serious and
sinful act which invalidates the fast?
The act which is the most sinful and
most serious amongst all of them which
invalidate the fast it is sexual
intercourse. that when you have a sexual
intercourse and when the two private
parts meet then your fast is invalidated
whether ejaculation takes place or not
and you have to repent for that you have
to complete the fast for that day and
you have to make it up later and you
have to pay a penalty that's kafara and
these are the three options that have
been given for a person to pay as a
penalty as a kafara But if a person can
do the first thing, he should not jump
to the second or the third. The first is
freeing a slave. If he cannot do that,
if he doesn't have the money or cannot
find a slave, then he can go to the next
option that is fasting consecutively for
60 days. If he cannot do that, if he's
unable to do that continuously fasting
for 60 days, if he fasts for a few days
and then one day doesn't fast, he should
start again. He should fast
consecutively for 60 days. If he doesn't
have the capacity to do that then what
he can do is he can feed 60 poor people
and each poor person should be fed with
approximately half s each sa is equal to
three handful of ostretched hand of
wheat. So half sa per person or the food
that is there of the land. So 60 poor
people you should feed. This is the kaf
the penalty for a person who breaks a
fast by having a sexual intercourse.